dank kurzer hoch luca nicht an der box
gratis
servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge heute spielen wir
wieder eine minecraft challenge und zwar
eine die ihr eigentlich schon kennt
nämlich locker sagt das ganze ein
bisschen zu optimieren haben wir jetzt
auch es ermöglicht dass luca auch sieht
was ich mache
denn wir haben uns den teamviewer
installiert das heißt luca sieht
eigentlich genau gerade alles was ich in
minecraft mache in echtzeit und kann
dann eben immer sagen was ich da machen
soll
aber ich erkläre die erstmal den
spielmodus auch vielleicht für alle die
zum ersten mal sehen das ist crazy balls
ist von lucky blog basiert der modus was
lucky box ist glücklich und die
platziert man so und dann läuft ein job
eiskalt ab und auch explodieren
das geht nicht also vielleicht wenn luca
sagt aber auch leute für die die es
nicht verstehen
der luca wird von uns also von max und
mir macht und mir immer luca genannt
immer ist so ich bin locker weil wir
irgendwie so dass wir in alberta die auf
renten immer näher dran hängen statt
also wie pizza jan r und luca
also wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr ihn ab
jetzt auch lokalen ok gut ja und lukas
du siehst was hier los ist und wie immer
gibt es bei luca sagt heute vier wünsche
für dich viermal war heute
special day und ich erklärte er kurz vor
den spielmodus also ich fange mit
tierärzte da rächt sich glücklicher blog
ja stimmt da rächt sich so ein timer
green walls und wenn der greenbox thema
abgelaufen ist fallen die grünen wollen
die fallen darunter auf dem boden und
dann kämpfe ich gegen die gegner hinter
dem green world davor kaufe ich mir die
ahler weise equipment von dem von den
ärzten lichtfarbe und dann dann etwas
später fallen die red bulls und dann
faltig gegen die hinter den red dot
genau dass ich und du hast heute wobei
wir sagen 34 zwischen zu viel für dich
oder nein gibt mir wir haben ja gesagt
drei plus eins
ich habe nachgerechnet gerade momentan
habe ich gerechnet
und 4 ja 33 bis 1 wenn du wie du darfst
frei sprechen aber ich werde natürlich
versuchen möglich schnell meine zwischen
zu verballern damit wir sind nicht sagt
kopf scheiße da die der die welt in
einer minute 13 fallen würde ich sagen
mein erster wunsch ist du warst die
teamviewer steuerung wieder an
also leute müssen wissen bei calima
teamviewer einfach klingt aller pc
steuern und ok ihr seht jetzt gerade
nicht deaktiviert und steuerung zu
lassen
luca luka geht's umgeht geht zu dem
typen
ich werde okay ich werde dir sagen ich
werde nicht eingreifen nicht oft als ich
werde jetzt nicht die ganze zeit so
total behindert ich würde mich allen
läufen nicht oft und ich würde nicht
wieder und soll total
ich bin normal weiter ja aber du kannst
quasi dann eingreifen
robert könnte eingreifen aber die sache
ist ich sehe das alles ein bisschen
verzögert das war zum beispiel auch so
wo du gerade den lucky blog unten
angeklickt hat bei mir stand noch
irgendwie noch zwei sekunden oder so und
bei dir war stand so yao ich habe gold
flutlicht bei mir steht auch noch von
2,8 okay gut er kann erzählen
ok also wären leichten delay drin
aber luca kann jetzt theoretisch nur
dass ihr euch will da nicht wundern wenn
irgendwelche seltsame dinge passieren
luca hat jetzt die theoretische und
praktische möglichkeit einfach in mein
spiel einzugreifen und da luca luka ich
muss ich den baustopp geben
lukas es wartet ab und hat einfach nicht
getroffen
den hole dir wohl ziemlich sehr gerne
haben ehrlich ja und luca leute diesem
ausrutscher das hat immer luca ich würde
es nicht einmal gefressen kommt den
hunger und zucker gegner
jetzt haben wir den hatte der mellon
arena kämpfen jetzt ja ja ich bin ich
als junger alter was geil geil jetzt
stoppt galerie 250 support
komme da raus komme da raus hat ich muss
gerade mal versuchen rauszukommen uns
immer gleich am arsch und sommer gleich
ziemlich okay nun wissen wir da
rausgekommen alter schwede packt alter
wie sind wir da raus gekommen
okay das hat das problem immerhin nicht
eingreifen nicht auch also ich werde
richtig anfängt so total behindert
können wir bitte diese diese phase
beenden
du hast einfach nur drei weitere was
soll da noch passieren ich bin jetzt
schon massiv gestört in meinem spiel
also im spiel dann aber nicht ich könnte
noch viel mehr spaß machen soll empfinde
ich auch schon aufhören können jaja
eingreifen können aber gut stimmt hat
nein ich bin alles dafür geben
ich hab den habe ich dann hab ich da
habe ich nein habe ich nicht da hab ich
nicht da hab ich nicht alter halbes jahr
hole holla what's my name eigentlich für
so am herzen
das ist ganz so knapp also ich kann dir
helfen
bloß nicht
man lernte heck doch hacker leute
springen einfach die nächste runde und
porten uns quasi wieder ins death match
immer weiter so leute zweite runde
wir haben uns bisher koopmann gekauft
damit sie überall umrüstung schärfe
eines poland wir haben auch paar
hübschen star im inventar und hier ist
unser erster gegner war ja ich bin
wieder da
lukas auch wieder da luke hat sich
gerade schön in betrieb
ganz teilemanagement effekt cdtm kennt
die zähne geputzt find ich gut denn für
ihn ist wichtig und ja jetzt geht's
wieder hier los die diesellok hätten es
vielleicht einfach etwas erfolgloser
versuch zu blocken
man ist immer das gleiche wo nehmen die
dieses pete bocian c8 das nicht ob ich
kids das ist glaube ich jetzt die sie
haben das ist immer das gleiche
spox die leute locker runter sie laufen
weg weil ich kann schlecht sind und dann
okay okay gut ok luca du hast noch drei
von vier
und ja ich zeig dir kurzem aus mir
machen kann hier kann man web'n'walk
blog kaufen das ist eine op lucky blog
eine gute waffe raus danke danke luca
danke dieses zog ihm fehlt ist übrigens
alles luca vogue -chefin verbrennung
neid macht jetzt keinen unsere mit der
maus war luca luka alter was acht level
wieder für die kacke ok dann kriegt acht
level was kann ich mir da noch einiges
also ich hab mir eine menge equipment
ich habe hier den meisten stars hatte
ich genau mein ding machen dass man kurz
zusammenlegen
sehr schön da so jetzt ist hier unten
sowohl gegner schreibt junge kämpfen das
war nicht ganz sein
ach ich habe schon die verbrennungs
vergessen
er backt in der luft war raus werden
junge hat einfach ein herz pass auf ich
hole mir den hunger denn du kannst du
dir einmal überlegen also ich habe schon
überlegt ob er kommt kann ich ihn bitten
hit geben etwas serverseitig scheiße lag
geschmack inka kelter wollen man
versucht alter mann versuchte es mit dem
bau zu ende und dann kommt der luca
einfach man ist es immer das gleiche wir
jetzt rum hat sich um den ja jetzt gehts
kissen dauert aber ich habe auch in rain
schnell aber jetzt brennt daher kommt
nicht weg habt ihr gesehen da nicht
retten konnte jetzt verdauen
okay doch ich will erst meine bahnen ich
kann ja nicht wünschen hier doch wussten
immer dass ich bin mega mega laut am
laufen band
ach ja ok heißt ich habe ihn okay hacker
oder was schreiben
das wird vom anti spam dings geblockt
glaube ich was wir schreiben alter ok
irgendwo ist übrigens die sache ja mein
dritter von vier wünschen in dem
deathmatch bleibst du die ersten zehn
sekunden auf der stelle stehen
du darfst zwar mit dem bogenschießen
noch schlagen aber du bleibst stehen die
ersten zehn sekunden alles sei okay das
match beginnt in vier sekunden
ich stelle mich einfach mal darf mit dem
bogenschießen 1 ob das 234 6 7 8 9 10
alter ist kein gegner ok etwas einen
finalen wunsch noch frei
ein hast du noch arbeite ich mich erst
mal kurz kurz hier alter das ist das
gemeinsam am anfang erstmal so die
fremdsteuerung zu aktivieren weil da
kannst du die ganze runde über scheiße
was das war der beste wünsche nicht
eingelöst hatte
ich glaube wirklich alter damit im video
geht es halt auch richtig gut also dass
es cool dass es so möglich ist
danke versteckt ihn wahrscheinlich 80
will kurz mal paar bögen kombinieren
heimstärke 31 da haben wir noch wickeln
aufmarsch wetter machen luca wenn du
jetzt ja horn wenn du einfach kurz luca
wenn du danke wir können keine schwerer
machen altermatt okay wenn zwei von
diesen op hemd aber wir können auch gar
nichts kaufen
natürlich egal wie luca luka nicht dass
die boarder luca nicht an der bande
ermordet aktivieren wir sind wir
ziemlich schnell tot wenn du das machst
gekürzt
dann kümmert luca luka es mich bitte den
töten danach ganz wieder fremdschäm
machen ist echt so weit dass mich nur
kurz denn töten wir können danach wieder
alles chillen und pisten und reil altern
eishockey erst aus der bonner bank kurz
hoch
vierter wunsch bitte gewinnen noch